- Thank you for having me here tonight.
My name's Chelsea Handler and
I am as white as they come.
I'm filming a documentary,
as you may or may not know
about white privilege.
- Oh.
- I'm clearly the beneficiary
of white privilege.
I want to know how to
be a better white person
to people of color.
We need to talk to people
who are white and stop asking
black people to solve our problems.
Do you think it exists?
- I wouldn't say it's totally nonexistent
but it's not something
that I see very commonly.
- But would you see it if you're white?
I got caught with dime bags on
me with my boyfriend Tyshawn
three times and every times
and every time he was arrested
and I was let go.
It never occurred to me
that it was a racial thing.
I shoulda known better.
- To us it's so hard for a black person
than it is for a white person.
(soulful music)
- You guys know where you come from.
You know your history.
We don't know that.
We still don't know if we were
related to kings or queens,
or if we were farmers, or if
we built houses, we don't know.
You guys know, that's a
privilege you guys have.
♪ Focus your pain ♪
- White people have to
have the conversation
with white people.
And so those are hard conversations.
- It's like talking about
porn at the dinner table.
(laughs)
You know.
I mean, obviously at my dinner
table that would be fine but.
- Lord have mercy.
- You do need to learn about others
but you also have to learn about yourself.
- Here I come white people.
(soulful music)
- It's great to talk about it
because you need to start somewhere.
But this rabbit hold goes deep.
Deeper than a documentary.